making these films is incredibly tough
and physical especially when you're
playing a character like spider-man
and in some cases it was way worse than
we could have imagined which two
spider-man actors nearly suffocated in
their masks how about the peter parkers
that really got battered up by willem
dafoe number one seriously what's this
dude's problem when i say there's like
blood sweat and tears i'm not
exaggerating it's true he's totally not
the green goblin spider-man face-off was
a brutal one for both performers
william and i both just collapsed to the
floor
and just because we were exhausted oh
and that blood sweat and tears tom was
talking about
i bust my hand up like my knuckles were
bloody
number two okay what did he do this time
injuries endured while facing the green
goblin aren't anything new to this
franchise during toby maguire's first
spider-man movie willem fully clipped
maguire's chin when they were duking it
out it's not a good call to mess with a
green goblin these days and it wasn't
back then either
number three usually you're supposed to
rest after being injured but not our ned
your shoulder was like dislocated oh
yeah but why would that stop him from
hanging off of some scaffolding to film
an intense stunt like this
it was pretty it was pretty crazy
crazy is one word for it but don't let
tommy hear you talk about it too much
you only just gave one shoulder so stop
complaining
number four
it's just i'm getting old late you know
we're throwing back to late winter 2021
filming was back up again after being
interrupted by the pandemic but then the
production came to a halt once more
i've hurt my knee so they've given me a
few days off so i've been sitting in the
house for the last three four days sort
of doing nothing honestly given the
intense stunts in these movies it's a
bit surprising this doesn't actually
happen more often than it does but hey
they did pick tom to be spider-man for a
reason
number five
wait isn't a helmet for safety
yeah typically it is unless you're on
the set of spider-man where off the bat
it just put tom holland in danger
instead of protecting him i ended up
cutting my face at one point on it it
just wasn't a very good design while the
marvel team doesn't always make the
adjustments on the suit tom requests yes
we're talking about the toilet zip again
i asked for a zip and i didn't get one
this particular issue was remedied
immediately
after all we can't let that pretty face
get cut up number six
is that why tom was gurgling through
lines on set okay so zendaya's worries
what's the pow
how is he going to get it out this is a
genuine concern
very valid
when the teenage holland was filming
this rigorous scene loads of drops of
water were collecting in his mask and
got all up in his business essentially
getting him waterboarded talk about
diving into the deep end number seven
hold up didn't we just talk about this
well sort of andrew garfield had his own
waterboarding by spidey suit mask
filming experience his first spider-man
movie getting that mask wet is no picnic
because that kind of restrictive
material is seriously not meant for
breathing easily in the best of
circumstances luckily the fight
coordinator expert andy armstrong was
there to suggest they just scrapped the
mask a simple but oh so effective
solution number eight
just when they were so close to
finishing the movie
tom holland had to go and ruin it the
actor was prepping to do some final
takes in new york and everyone was so
close they could taste it that is until
holland headed down the stairs with a
suitcase in tow
i fell and like tweaked my acl a little
bit sort of like
down the stairs i did that
seriously dude if we're being honest
though the real highlight is the fact
that hotshot holland was still looking
around his own suitcases yeah that's a
pretty peter parker thing to do
number nine it's okay we can cg the
blood
but it was luckily just before my last
shot
yeah thank goodness
i basically fell over and bashed my face
in front of about 200 crew members so
not my most heroic moment that face bash
produced a fair amount of blood but time
was of the essence so the whole crew
went on shooting literally fixing the
cosmetic damage in post via the cg once
they wrapped of course tom's face got
the proper medical care as well
a solid first impression holland number
10.
wait
how can a stone bruise all jokes aside
emma stone did do her fair share of
stunts but none of those did her any
harm it was actually the safety
equipment that caused some lasting
damage because of how tight all the
harnesses had to be they hoist you and
there's a lot of bruising but it's good
bruising
good bruising for sure
well honestly it's not too surprising
how easily she shrugged it off she is a
tough one
number 11 more tissues on set for andrew
okay so nosebleeds kind of inherently
come as part of the contract when you're
playing spider-man with all that
swinging around and kissing in the rain
and in his first movie as spider-man you
know garfield was sporting the tissues
up his nose look just so the team could
get on with filming and not have to cgi
blood out afterwards and that's
ridiculous
number 12. oh toby why'd you have to lie
about it
there was a time when the crew thought
toby maguire had suffered a back injury
filming the spider-man sequel but in
reality he was just trying to get some
cash added to his deal he of course
admitted the truth apologized and the
movie got made but sam raimi wasn't
going to let him get away with the stunt
so easily
my back
open my back
yeah
the scene kinda lands different knowing
the story behind it doesn't it we gotta
give it to raymie though definitely a
solid and hilarious payback number 13
okay it's bonus time we know we said we
were covering spider-man after injuries
but these other marvel actor injuries
were just too wild not to share filming
black panther wakanda forever in boston
went downhill real fast when the
princess of wakanda herself leticia
wright was doing a stunt a stunt rig
gone wrong made for a chaotic day and
wright was rushed to the hospital to
treat her injuries luckily the actress
was on the mend and able to get back to
filming soon enough
number 14.
is it even possible to recover properly
while doing so much action scarlett
johansson went through a battering
performing tons of her stunts for iron
man 2. and the rough days on set didn't
change during avengers assemble it was
just all one big injury you get used to
it i guess
it's a good thing that was her attitude
early on because from the looks of it
she got very used to it
[Music]
number 15 sorry how does this make sense
apparently when you're as tough as rdj a
broken limb is just another day at work
and can actually come in handy i broke
my ankle once but then that gave us time
to do some more script revisions yeah
super casual broken ankle no big deal
well he is iron man for a reason
really isn't that big a deal it happens
all the time
all right so the respect level we have
for all these spider-man actors has shot
through the roof after all these years
and so many spider-men having trouble
nearly waterboarding themselves we'd
think somebody on the team would take
some action on it we're with zendaya on
this one
[Music]